howdy folks welcome to this gamespot
video sponsored by tcl
today we are playing resident evil
village on the tcl 85-inch q-led
tv a part of the xl collection which
features the thx
certified gaming mode that is all about
low input lag
it also has high variable refresh rate
so there's low stutter
no frame rate jibber jabber that's going
to get in the way of you having your
best experience
we also have uh the ability to switch
into game mode
and then automatically switches back to
the previous tv mode you were
in for the best cinematic experience
like watching movies and streaming
television and lastly
the aipq enhanced mode
which is a an ai machine learning that
is going to enhance color contrast
and all that jazz make sure your game
looks the best
it possibly can and joining me today
is the man the man versus
game to be playing resident evil village
jason
ma'am how are you kurt uh i'm great it's
great
to be here i just want to thank you all
for having me here and um
i'm excited to get down on some resident
evil village on this gorgeous tv
to endure the survival i do 85
television um and you're speaking yes
and it's just so striking that you're
going to be striking your way
through resident evil village
mercenaries mode the action-packed mode
uh that resident evil is so iconic for
yeah so before we get into that however
where can people find you oh man uh well
like kurt
said i am man versus game uh most people
just call me man
uh but you can find me you know on
twitch of course twitch.tv slash
man versus game um from there you can
find my other info on the panels so
we don't need to go over that
but in the meantime till now the time
begins
when you must strap on that tie which
may be loose by the end of this
my sweat might be pouring out uh to
go into the thick of it and see how we
do and
put this tv to the test with
an action-packed mode that is resident
evil village mercenaries
man i barely touched this mode uh
i i jammed through the main game uh you
know to prepare for this
uh love the story love all the aspects
of that
it's operatic i know it's it's it's
going to be difficult not to like get
into
all the spoilers but we're going to keep
this as spoiler free as we possibly can
yes yes and thankfully mercenaries
doesn't try to that ground and also it
is a much
different pacing than the flow of
residual village which is much more
survival which is much more of a slog
in certain places but this is uh going
to push you to your limits and i'm going
to be here
to maybe support you or just watch uh in
in your misery as we go on
yes yeah uh well let's let's boogie
let's get it on let's start
um now as you can see these are not my
scores i just want the audience to be
aware
when you see these terrible scores
coming in from me uh
so the village let's start with the
village three areas sure
let's do it uh the duke
the duke looking his absolute finest on
85 inches
of pure q led
low frame rate full refresh rate
the size of this tv is so striking
i know for a large man to like to
already like
it's like you can see his gut just like
spilling look at him even he's amazed by
how he looks yeah
like i look so good look at this he's
never looked better
so to get into the thick of it um you
haven't had much time with this
so do you want me to i'm a bit of a
veteran
yes and please normally you know on my
streams i'm not about this
uh but for today for the sake of just
you know getting only lean in every once
in a while
oh oh no please let me know we've
already discussed some strategies
yeah we have differing strategies right
which is interesting
so like can i there's one little thing
that i usually do right before again i
think of this
sure absolutely i usually sell the ammo
that i pick up so like right when you
pick up that ammo there
yeah i tend to sell off the ammo that i
know i won't be using and lean into like
the one gun and then use that
uh that money to upgrade the weapon i
will be using
interesting so you're like a one gun
kind of guy
that's my strategy like it does get to
certain points later on
uh when i do usually invest into a
shotgun but that usually comes like in
later areas
but um sometimes i go all in and up on a
pistol okay
interesting well i i i will believe that
i'll leave that up to you
i'll try this out uh let's see first aid
hank and ammo the shock enamel sniper
rifle ammo
i guess i won't be using that at all
i'm not a sniper person this feels so
weird i like the sniper
i really do you know what why aren't you
alive i'm giving i'm going to hold on to
the apple
okay i changed my mind that's what i'm
saying even i'm not going to get in the
way of
of of uh your intuition so i only have
yeah
that's we start with yes so you can
choose to you know like you have enough
money to at least like start with a new
uh with a companion thing or you can
even sell your pistol off and just go
all in oh that sounds insane
the the pistol is like just the core
yes you gotta have that's like the first
gun that i
power up uh and i don't really bother
with rate of fire reload speed ammo
capacity
it's just the power for me for you you
go all in yeah you just want a volcanic
burst yeah uh for me it's it's all about
uh
that's why you're a sniper person yeah
accuracy exactly uh i go for those head
shots
um but uh man what is this uh
m1911 i do love this gun so
when uh it's for something like this
i'm in mercenaries mode uh playing on
something like this
like the game itself is already so
immersive it's already a first person
uh version of the resident evil games
which is you know is
was introduced in resident evil 7 so
many moons ago
um but like a big part of these games is
the immersion like thankfully this game
has 3d audio integrated if you use
headphones which is already terrifying
um but i'm personally excited to have
like this
this theater-esque experience oh yeah
fully engrossed with lichens i stole
ghouls the thing that just caught my ear
during that intro was uh talking about
the ai
aspect yes of the uh lighting the
that just blows my mind yeah and which
we'll get into like once we
once we start looking at that but you
know it's it's able to
it's most specifically when you know
you're playing older
uh games that are not in 4k or movies
that are not 4k and it's ability to
upscale it
to something like an 85-inch screen and
like fill the gaps
um using their ai technology is really
what's impressive and
it's like someone like me who enjoys to
revisit older games too
that may not have gotten the 4k facelift
yet um
it's hugely beneficial something that
i'm really eager
and excited about but we are playing on
a playstation 5 today
so uh we are going to be getting the
full use of
4k streaming on twitch yes you'd think i
would have the the best gear and the
best you know monitor
refresh rate i don't even bother going
above you know the 60 frames for my
setup just because of the streaming
aspect of it so this is going to be
such a treat smooth for me but let's get
to it yes
for the love of let's go uh you're just
dragging it out am
uh this is going to be such a disaster
let's uh where's that door right there
there it is let's go and the struggle
begins i know
the door man versus doors i know
uh did i oh this looks so good
there we go beautiful oh god even for a
game that is
both you know i don't know what you call
it currents in previous gen now
yeah i guess carrying a previous gen ps4
ps5 um
the sheer detail and like density this
of uh of just like the snow and like
being able to see
uh the bell tower in the distance um i
love it
that i got so immersed in this game and
i gotta say i'm so glad that i
played it off stream uh just so i could
have those moments
you know um until we throw into the
thick of it
right right which really i i always feel
like
even now like i'm not you know blasting
away enough because
right this game trained me yes to hold
you know
that ammo was so precious i know it's an
odd
uh like juxtaposition to fly in
from a campaign that only has like
glimpse it's an action game
without a doubt but it still doesn't um
it trains you in a way to like to care
about what you've got on
and what you're youtube to be using and
mercenaries is like throw in the drum
and base
get it right uh give the man 200 rounds
yeah
no brainer uh this is as you can see i'm
a hedgehog
um you didn't get a sniper rifle not yet
i did not uh
i figured maybe i wouldn't need it yet i
don't know
it's just time to go i know what you're
doing you're pacing yourself out
this is the way i basically played
through the game and i know like you
keep you know mentioning it's like this
is not the main game no
you're but like you know i carry over
some of my uh my strategies like i'm a
go for the knee guy
and then and then unload rounds and into
uh into them
when they're at their worst state those
sad sacks of
ghoulie flesh they're at their lowest i
know not that they aren't at their
lowest they're beautiful creatures
they every every every being has its own
place in this
grand cosmic dance and what how
more beautiful can you look on the tcl
85-inch television screen man i just
can't get over how like how big
the actual screen is i use i used to
have like a 74-inch tv
this is a 85 yeah blessed it's uh
i got to get me one of these honestly
the goal has spawned
yeah well that's a funny that's like the
funky thing about these days
um or like this new generation of uh of
gaming with the ps5 and the xbox series
x and s um as i feel like we had a major
upgrade
in televisions and like of course
there's um
there's several varieties now between
both qled
and oled um screens and
i think um i like this is the first time
buying a new console that was like i you
you
some tvs can't handle the output uh the
new consoles
can do and thankfully like you know for
stuff like this that that isn't a
problem
um like this tv is is built uh
manufactured and designed
uh to for low input latency for
to make sure that like everything we're
doing as a gamer uh is like
as pinpoint as to what it was intended
to be
which which is everything for me the the
game mode
on your tv is super important just
because that lag
you don't want the lag and you don't get
the lag the convenience of not having to
switch
back and forth when you're watching
titanic
and you want you want to make sure
you're not watching titanic in gamer
mode
no you want to see it in the best
cinematic picture mode you can
for sure yeah um because uh i don't know
see the tech aspect of these things i
don't i'm i'm very much a layman a lay
person
if you will uh now i i just went through
the area here
you had like 10 more enemies you could
have got you see
what kind of grade am i going to get
here the last time i i didn't go through
you know that area that's okay yeah i'm
learning lucky for you there's three
areas
uh this particular one oh gosh so now's
your chance
to talk to big boy duke yes if you're
going to lean into uh
that that that hand rifle uh the shotgun
ammo i just
that i guess i will sell it's amazing
how we play i love
watching other people in the decisions
they make because like so before this
even started i would like we like
i was like oh you gotta go for the knees
you gotta like i have like this whole
strategy of how i take care of these
dudes
yeah um i love the shotgun don't get me
wrong
i really do it's a pistol boy this mode
i
the the pistol is my you know but i also
like
i also do put the rate of fire up a
little bit really interesting yeah
depending depending on um i've gotten to
a point with the with
mercenaries mode where i don't upgrade
rate of fire and i go
ammo clip all the way up and power all
the way up so i'd never have to reload
and we'll clip sure yeah i later on in
the game when i had some extra funds
i did upgrade the the clip size right
because that's helpful but anything that
fires those bullets faster
that's like uh like a liability that's
that's bad for me yes
because then i'll find myself with none
of it so you don't have enough for a
sniper
but you might be you could you could
probably sell a
thing or two more yeah or you can just
go in why not
why not just go i i'm gonna go with this
man i've got 331
ammo which is something that is not
common
and resident evil unless you're chris
redfield oh no yeah
exactly oh gosh here we go
now i've got the ammo but it's it's like
in my head this game trained me to the
point where
like i will barely fire off around i
mean it's not right on their head
ethan winters also still moves like he's
like got
like rocks in his boots this is true uh
i mean he's still like he's not like a
superhuman
in his movement by any means now have
you gotten a chance to play any of the
reverse the no i haven't
and i am oh so curious same
uh and i know it's been delayed um
but i am very eager because capcom and
resident evil has
uh a fascinating history with their
online games
um they attempted many many different
things
who is that beside me all right uh they
still have to do a great job of
overwhelming you
uh despite overpowering you with 300
rounds oh for sure yeah and
that head blast looks so good oh it's so
satisfying
it's it's like you know it's great just
you know with like the power fantasy of
video games that i certainly get into
uh but with this kind of survival horror
it's such a relief
yes because you know for a fact they
will not be getting up from that
all right here we go so i guess so i
play this at home very frequently
uh i also have a tcl at home um but not
this
i don't have anything from the xl series
i don't have any or the the excel
collection
um or of this caliber but um
it is theatrical there it is to say the
least
oh yeah man
the in terms of like the uh
you know dark to the light yes aspect
ratio
yes and that's like the great thing
about um qlad you know is the ability to
have like um
you can play it in a brighter
environment if that's a way
i mean whether like we have a window
behind us um and it doesn't cause a
problem on the blacks the blacks still
look black
um and that like that's always
even just like a concern for me uh
playing at home i don't have the luxury
of having like a legit
setup um but you know
cue lead screens they're backlit they
got the thing to go what'd you just do
the the handgun handgun master so i just
want to be
you're going to the curt route yeah dude
i'm going to be master of one
so this is where this is where
mercenaries gets a little wonky because
like you have to
run around like you really have to like
find where the enemies are
um and pick up extra time because
sometimes they'll like spawn back
at the beginning of where you started
and you have to basically just keep
running back and forth
yeah i'm too and as you see like this is
how i played through the game
was that dude eating a snowball
is that like cherry slurpee
this is like just like scooping off the
snow from the ground like ah yes
i can't eat ethan winters he's just you
know
he's like wolves eating snow
obviously so he's just doing his thing
that lighting i would give that snow
torches yeah everything
i just everything in this game looks so
gorgeous uh
that was like a slick dodge yeah
unintentionally like that
yeah i like uh these arrows are no
they just move around the man and like
like the big lebowski you know it's like
i somehow someway just make it through
just completely
unaware of what's going on except for
your carpet oh god here we go and we're
on a beautiful carpet this is looking
bad
oh god i got it you're fine
you're fine look you're dodging arrows
unintentionally yes
okay they're moving around you oh oh oh
get back get back the lichens
oh god oh there it is this is the first
champ
oh that's a harsh one okay we're good
we're good there you go
yeah take that plenty of hit points
not a concern uh
so you got a power up there the the
up top oh yeah i'm going for that
there we go i uh
oh what was that what did you just get
hit as i was happening i guess
let's see healthy shotgun master man i
wish i had no
you're not a shotgun you sold the ammo
so healthy we'll go happy
hopefully i won't have to rely on the uh
oh god the blade
i don't use yeah i don't use the blade
much in these parts um
for some reason in the main game i
always i like to have that out that was
the neat that was that was the knee
strategy like the old like that was like
you go for the knee
and you get them with a knife while
they're on the ground oh okay uh
the oh god you still got you still got
enemies five more
where okay so this is where like if you
run back a little bit and take a look
around
um i've got a full minute uh
somebody's shooting stuff
just go go i think he's up there behind
you oh oh here we go
that's in you feel free by the way to
tell me exactly
you know where i need to go or where
should be going
uh just eat some snow okay just stop and
take a break
enjoy enjoy the the the beautiful
handfuls of snow that'll like it i don't
know where the hell that dude i see the
guy's shadow
there is oh my goodness there you go oh
god but at the time
okay you shot an air this is fine
you shot an arrow you did that was good
all right makes you feel badass
all right i'm getting out of here yeah
uh i'm going to try to get out of here
this is all my fault i feel i was like
you have five guys to kill i was ready
to go
i was like don't do it yet it's like uh
oh i'm dying to win this for you
did you oh okay you could do it you
could do it
man burst time hold on uh see this is
what you're talking about with ethan
running around like he's got rocks
i know oh god go go go go go go go go
this is gonna be heartbreaking
yeah but look how crisp it looks when it
says time up curt
at least at least uh at least it's
presented at its absolute best
even when you're losing i can see it so
clearly i know my failure
it's never looked so good okay it's an
all-encompassing experience
83 000. so what does that mean to you
uh well it could be a pb for me
oh god it's a c okay we got to restart
and uh i at least want to get through
all the areas
i think i'm distracting you it's just
i've never played on a tv this
i think it's i think it's i think it's
uh my commentary
the tv being uh overwhelming
like awe inspiring
i i want to try going for like your
your strat and see we've got the shotgun
ammo
because yeah i just so what i yeah so
what i do is i sell all the shotgun ammo
i sell all the rifle ammo and then i
sell the lemmy
itself um get that upgraded pistol
and then i go for uh the
i can't remember the name of it um it's
all that stuff
keep the handgun ammo keep the hand
which i had yeah keep the handgun ammo
okay good yeah so now you're freaking me
out
we'll make it um and then
uh i buy the that that can machine
looking pistol it's not a machine gun
the one over oh okay
well yeah i didn't even buy this in the
main game because i just thought oh no
that's that yeah i almost passed on it
too but it's not a machine gun it's like
it's a machine operated
okay pistol so you can hold the trigger
down and keep shooting but it doesn't
work like a machine gun
okay um well i'll give it a shot yeah
and then i upgrade that
uh i go i go power the power all the way
yes
um just as much power as i can jam into
it and then
uh yeah that's it and then i go and go
in
that's it and we're done i'm ready
this is the curt strategy we're gonna
see the the learning curve here right
before your very eyes
uh if i don't do better than a c this
time i don't know
but you know before we like before we
jump into it you know like this is
uh like the the main things here is like
this has the thx
certified gaming mode uh which is all
about the ability to
to specifically lower
input lag which is great because with
variable refresh rate that's also
low latency it's supposed to even out
stutter uh with frame rate so it's like
that's what this tv is able to do so
we're going in now
all in all in and it's power the power
of the telly
the power of the pistol um i kind of
wish
that you know there that i was
experiencing some kind of uh you know
input lag or
any kind of crutch yes you know exactly
what i'm getting look at this
this is brilliant it's going much better
okay maybe
i can't believe i slept on the uh i keep
wanting to call it an uzi because in
my i mean it wouldn't it doesn't look
like your run-of-the-mill
uh handgun there we go i see and i'm
just again
taking so long think of the time limit
man
okay eight wow look at those call of
duty moves
that's just me gripping the controller
man yes that right analog um
okay here we go money you need delay
oh yeah that's amazing that's good
this is the way to go oh yeah no i don't
even
not not messing with the legs oh man the
goats
i was so sad that i didn't get all the
goats i uh so the problem me
during my playthrough so for those of
you who may have not played village or
go through like there's a hunting aspect
in certain parts of the game
um and i just thought initially
that hunting the animals like gave you
like additional first aid kits
but i didn't realize until like halfway
through
that they gave you permanent upgrades
and i was like i don't want to kill
these dudes
like i like they're just buying their
own damn business
that was one of the most frustrating
aspects of my playthrough was uh
you know i saw the achievement that you
could hunt animals yes i was like oh
can't wait to do that
found some fish and i got them and i was
like oh
so do i eat them are they healing items
and then so i didn't do anything with
them and then i found some more fish and
then the game
you know there was a pop-up it was like
uh give these to the duke
i was like okay and so at the time
i could just i all i could do is sell
them yes the duke
yes and then realizing after the fact
that it's like oh i can oh
god but i will say like uh i i didn't
kill them because i was like they're
minding their own business i don't need
first aid kits
i'm surviving just fine without them wow
i was like i'm gonna this goat looks
great
this pig looks great i want to stay out
of its way these chickens could probably
go
the pig and i had like an epic tussle
that thing was obnoxious yes it was um
attack when switching between enemies uh
that's not really my style but none of
the other the thick skinned let's go
okay so bad with these like snap
decisions
uh all right especially when you're on
the spot yes exactly ripping for
survival
16 of you guys left here we go
now it looks so sweet where's that mine
oh yeah like frame rate rise there's
like a moment like this uh
like a moment when you were like just
like zipping and like turning around in
certain environments
and like i it was like it's it's almost
like
bizarre for my eyes it's like an i must
like to see it like oh my god
here we go yeah man as a guy
who is currently now in his 40s uh you
know grew up playing atari
oh yes oh yes thank you kurt and i
appreciate that
um but guyana's 40s
i grew up playing atari you know
nintendo and
imagine playing a commodore 64 on this
guy yeah that was like my first system
a commodore 64. uh wow
shout outs to commodore but i
games are just getting so gorgeous i
know like i just
trip on that i hope i never stop
tripping on how
gorgeous games are getting oh boy well
that's another thing too
i really and like this goes back to the
um
the upscaling the ai upscaling this does
um i know we're playing uh a new game
uh on the playstation 5. so
there's certain aspects like we're
seeing it in like the way that it was
intended to be seen
oh wow but i do there's a part of me
that's like i wonder what it's like to
to play um maybe like ps3 even xbox 360
games
um upscale to 4k and this like um
and just to see like that i feel like
that would be like one of the true
moments like to see like
having to see how this ai pushes right
up scaling for games
yeah yeah that just again blows my mind
yeah
look into more of like how that works
right i like learns to
present the game exactly looking better
you know as
the more you play it yeah and like
there's like certain movies too
um uh i mean for some reason in my brain
this is like
the first thing that keeps coming my
mind was like man jackie chan's police
story
85-inch tcl screen uh that's the first
movie that i would watch on
oh really probably next to terminator 2
so i'd be like jackie chance
please story let's go mine would
probably be fear and loathing in las
vegas
uh and crazy uh madness i just love his
his uh exaggerated like fisheye lens you
know the like
ultra wide screen kind of look i'm like
everyone like
inches away exactly exactly now this i'm
guessing is
like the enemy has to be very far away
for that uh this is where like i
like i don't mess with like i think this
is for these folks
for you long-range sniper uh friends
i gotta keep taking this thick skin
because i don't you wait do you already
have two of them
yes what am i doing i know i mean it's
not you it's the the hands that you've
been dealt that's alright that's right
it's the rng yes uh everybody judging me
right now i just want to say
you've all been there i'm only judging
you and i'm not judging you because this
is my method i told you to do
these this is my strategy i was like
just do this i like this i like
all in on a pistol i feel silly not you
know pump the power out
sleeping on this uh this gun so
we got two more enemies to take out
there's one of them i see one right
there
wow see already doing better
but i know uh until you unload a
a clip above his head it's like a
rainbow
rainbow bullet rainbow
yeah we're gonna start a new show here
called bullet rainbow
um where we play
uh violent action games uh instead of
reading books just to promote the idea
oh man so from this point on i usually
continue
just like selling selling shotgun and
rifle ammo and just continue to go all
in on pistol
this is the gun yeah this is yeah i i am
loving this um
so let's get in there shotgun ammo don't
need it who knows maybe
at one point you're gonna be like maybe
it's time to buy a rifle
uh i like the rifle um i did use it
quite a bit in the
you know playing through the main game
but we've got other areas to go too it's
like this is like this is only the first
the village then we have the castle and
then we have uh the factory
the factory is much more um narrow but i
think the castle would be pretty
beneficial
for the sniper rifle when we get to that
so far it's it is very
um you know more like close quarters
kind of kind of fighting so not too
worried about that let's see if we can
upgrade the power that is that is
paramount for this this build
okay that's it not going for
not extending the clip i uh
i feel like i can it's expensive
this stuff really adds up you do have
money this man
i do uh not enough first time no no
all right this is fine you're gonna be
just fine
uh what's this mercenaries rankings oh
wow i have a ways to go
okay reward triple s the village dang
unlockability magic magazine uh unlock
stage the castle okay
well i guess i'm not gonna worry about
these too much it is crazy how much this
mode
changes up i know the gameplay i know
and like taking it back into
like the normal campaign and like trying
to play it that way is like is just as
much of a flip flop for it right so
the one thing i really appreciate in
general too is like recently
with my own tcl tv um is
like kind of like the magic of game mode
and then going back to maybe watching
titanic
uh and how it flips uh automatically and
i don't even worry about it at all
oh really um and that's like just like
one of those little things where i was
like it's just like
once you set it up like hdr and all that
jazz um
it's just kind of like a beautiful and
beautiful convenience you don't really
think about it oh you can't go back
which somebody like something like that
for me i need that
yes because i would be constantly
forgetting to flip the
mode and to make sure titanic looks the
best it can look uh
we were just mentioning titanic before
we started uh
this guy's never seen titanic i've never
seen titanic but i'm preparing
uh for uh and knowing that
my tv my tcl tv
is going to know that i'm watching
titanic
and it'll be like you're not playing
resident evil village anymore you don't
need
all that that low latency you need
the best looking cinematic experience
possible we're switching out a game mode
pal
and you're going to see leo painting his
french girls
and billy zane with his eyebrows um
just being angry with that smug pretty
boy face
just being sexist and you just hate him
you love him you love to hate him yeah
that billy's ain't is that what it is in
titanic
uh yeah he's you don't really like him
he's
he's one of those spoiled clearly i
clearly i i would know
yeah you see you have a wonderful movie
to watch
you know they don't die in the end do
they
the [ __ ] makes it through right my lips
are sealed yep
everything's okay cameron really he
really uh subverted everybody's
expectations
with with that ending like the super
raft it just pulls it back up
uh where am i going here we go
yeah that's titanic is like actually
like right before the future war starts
in terminator
yeah there you go that's like they're
the surviving kinds sky not everything
is what sunk the uh uh the titanic in
the first place
i like this there's this dude eating the
snow again i like the the uh
oh you got the combusting the the blow
up yes that's like one of the best ones
that was always the first one i get
definitely excited me because i
yeah that was like no no uh
no choice i'm taking it you like ran in
while he was like drawing that string
back
you gotta be bold you got to wade into
the enemy shoot them in the belly that
you just abandoned his bow he was like i
don't want this thing
he's like you know what i don't want to
deal with this guy running into me i'm
trying to shoot this thing
am i picking up the layer okay yes now i
i just want to make it through this area
yeah so this is where is this the one
you stopped you we didn't finish last
time
yes that's all my fault i take that i
take full responsibility i'm going to go
with this
and just say it is where it was here you
go
headshot headshot there's also the song
that i really like
oh this one man i was digging that that
uh that drone base
come here you hey there it is
i i love that you can see the arrows
like
like like somehow you're magically just
like stepping aside them
oh yeah zoop right by you well i mean
everything looks so smooth and clear
i know it's amazing now
okay if you want to feel an arrow
zipping
by you yeah this is the tv to get
man it really i don't know if i can
really
overemphasize just like the the the size
of
like 85 inches it's enveloping my entire
like field of vision right now
and it's also like another thing to uh
that's always like a
i guess like i have to consider um
like while the world is like tiptoeing
back into like a theater
into movie theaters like there is still
an element that's like we are still
going to be getting
uh big hollywood releases day one
stuff like hbo max um like
kong vs godzilla and like combat and
like um i didn't have a movie theater
experience
for those um and this is like one of
those things where like if that was
you know if that's the path we're going
down um it's kind of silly
if that's something you're passionate
about you know just not just gaming but
watching movies as well
um so many enemies still now i want to
say i for one
hope that we do continue down that path
yeah oh yeah where is he he's right
above you oh god
this is the same no right about turn
around to your right to your right like
one other
oh there it is my goodness there you are
come here you
oh those guys are wily okay so
i do want to go back down though and i
hear somebody
i think they might be coming to you i
think there's one on your left as well
they're going to roll to me oh my gosh
yes yeah i think they're all absolutely
correct yeah they are here
okay i need to calm down
man versus game the nerves are coming in
hey analog that's fine i could take that
the goal spawned you've got thick skin
you have three chicks you know right i
hope so
i'm going to be the only upgrades you
were given with the curt knee
brilliant you have one more to get uh
one more enemy
supposedly no there's 22 over there oh
no i think he's right above you again i
think he's behind you turn up you are
absolutely right
there he is oh god bim bam boom slim
[ __ ] i am
that was amazing i want you to know i am
shaking right now all the way that arrow
flew off
all right i'm getting out you did it ah
it's not pretty
but 40 seconds left 47 seconds left
it's better oh man you didn't lose
you know is this one of those things
where it's like it's like painful
for you to watch no no it's exhilarating
because you
we we were talking about resident evil
and like you're you are a huge fan
a little bit of the series yeah yes all
28 games
see i've i've played so i feel like i
hit like the main you know like
uh i played resident evil 2 um
four five my buddies you played good
ones
yeah yeah exactly i played the good ones
um
i mean mercenaries is like uh like
mercenary started in resident evil
3 nemesis back in the day with fixed
camera angles and tank controls and all
of its glory
that sounds insane but you know like as
most of us you know
remember like mercenaries didn't really
come into its like fullest form until
resident evil 4.
which a lot of the elements that this
game uh borrows from
comes from although like i think village
in many ways take something from
the entire franchise like every single
game sure in some way shape or form
but uh yes seeing mercenaries like this
is actually um
mercenaries was in wasn't n7 but i think
this is one of the
one of the best mercenary modes that
we've seen um
i think revelations two has a really
good mercenaries mode now i'm nerding
out i'm resonating
these are some deep cuts versus the
revelations to mercenaries mode
is uh is the without a doubt the most
arcadey of them all
um yeah i love that i i love like the
damage numbers popping up
yes i love very gamey games
gamey games okay and this one of course
i mean village is
uh takes it up a notch in in in the
gaminess
for sure um just it really does kind of
ratchet up uh
a lot i was just thinking just like the
fantasy aspect of it
it's really it's like it's it's horror
like it's horror fantasy it's really
like i remember like halfway through
not i'm not gonna spoil anything i know
i was just gonna say
when you finally when you get an 85-inch
tcl tv and
and get to engross yourself into fresno
village and all of its spooks scares and
action-packedness uh it goes it gets
into some like
fantastical elements um at some parts in
the game that like took me by complete
the surprise
oh for sure um uh i i had a blast
playing through this game
and it really see and this is where i i
have to admit i did not i
skipped out on seven and it this is
much more frightening seven is seven is
far scarier that's what i've read yeah
it's um it's a very different
paced game it has like glimpses and
elements of of like
backtracking and some of the things that
like define the the genre and franchise
um but it's i think it's like through
and through first and foremost horror
game when this is like a fantasy action
horror game
right look at duke good old duke
uh very interesting character it's it is
difficult sitting here you know
not you know trying to avoid the
spoilers
because uh man if you haven't played
this game there is a lot going on
uh a lot of reveals a lot a lot of
mysteries
a lot of a lot of intrigue
now this is a big moment for you i just
keep this is the last this is the last
part of this area by the way
right third third and final whatever
zone or area for this this level
um do you have money to spend go on it's
only 22 000
i mean a shotgun i guess
i sold all the shotgun ammo why wouldn't
you go
it's your heart a sniper
you know sniper's great i really feel
like you're you're over emphasizing like
my sniper love i love the shotgun i
probably use the shotgun more than the
sniper rifle
here i am being like sell all of your
ammunition and buy a sniper rifle
man i don't know um
this is fine i just i want to i want to
be like a one gun
kind of guy okay and uh i'm not going to
be switching guns the old
eel cowboy yeah the duke has never
looked better in this size
he's already big i honestly you know in
some ways
seeing it like this it's maybe the
closest
i'll actually get to feeling what it's
like to be in the room with duke
which you're like it's beautiful it's an
experiment
it's an experience uh i don't know if i
want to say
pleasants look at them all together yeah
they really go all out with their
characters daydreaming
big guy yeah the lady
she's not the only big character yes
there's many big characters
to behold on a big tv oh boy
all right here we are big tv to hold all
these big characters there are so many
like my new details i really didn't get
the catch
uh until seeing it like this like there
was like certain reflections like
i saw on the window when the shack you
were just in that like didn't really
like pop out to me until
um this particular playthrough
um and pardon me i wish that i could uh
you know pay a little bit closer
attention to
like that's my enjoyment you just get to
sit here and watch
exactly where you're trying to be like
wow do you see how beautiful this game
is exactly i'm just trying to
he was like no dude i'm trying to
survive just trying to like make it to
the next
house oh god don't forget the upgrade
behind you there you go oh there is an
upgrade yeah yeah yeah
dear lord there it is that would have
been nice yeah
well here's a little pro tip you want to
grab those
upgrades before you start going and
fighting the enemies i adore all the
thick skinned
upgrades you have it's uh
i the choices were terrible it was like
knifing somebody i don't know they're
all for guns i was not using
initial attack does more damage than the
yeah i like that assassination
dash with the knife equipped with the
blade mat see this is exactly what i'm
talking about
it was like nice be like two knife
things yeah this is what we got
so brake shot it is big shot boom that's
how you end up with three
uh thick skinned oh beautiful
oh man i'm also one of those guys that
just cannot help
but like reload oh yeah every five
bullets
yeah there's a you know there's always
the
the old tactic of um switching guns
reloading so it's like when i do
eventually get the shotgun
um in certain hairy situations um
i'll switch the shotgun use that before
i reload my pistol then go back and
reload
but that's usually one of the reasons
why i go for all power
and then upgrade my clip all the way so
i just don't even have to worry about it
sure even though i still like out of
habit i'm just like constantly reloading
every single shot um okay
it goes get them head shots in come on
i just man i know i'm going to be
getting that c
but
it is uh just taking a nap by the door
all right
it is interesting um you know i was
reading a lot about
seven and uh oh
hey there you go i remember you oh boy
oh boy this guy
come here brilliant there it is
i know where to strike on those guys
coming to this guy's house just standing
in a room like hey
i have a drill in my arm what was he
doing just considering you want to stay
for dinner
it would be great if you went for
thanksgiving again you're just like
pistol master that speaks to me i'm
gonna go thick skin
people like why did we hire this guy
okay um okay
so yeah you gotta go down that uh that's
that confusing thing where like it's not
in the room it shows you it's not there
i like the subtle direction
you know that uh you know good
developers have where
like anything yellow in this game yes
yellow tape go to the yellow yeah
i haven't that poor guy ate too much
snow maybe just
off himself just too much to deal with
i'd like to think that wouldn't be me i
mean i would i would
you're the like you're in the home
stretch oh yeah um
you're doing far better uh than your
first time around
yeah see and this is what i like to do
is share my
my learning curve with the audience
here we go so that everyone knows he can
be taught oh
i somebody behind me love seeing the
arrows fly i know i've talked about that
like six million times yeah
but i almost feel like uh like it's it's
it has not been as apparent to me
right um i sound it sounds excessive and
silly but it's like there's a part of me
that's like um
like they don't stand out to me as
normal in one of my normal playthroughs
it's like the the ability like the like
the frame rate the the refresh rate
on this thing right um like makes it
seem
so like crystal clear like almost like
cliche it's like
you're almost really there how did i
miss
that but you're true like with
everything being smoother
uh and crisper even just catching peace
seeing things i normally don't
no this is great ah there we are that's
my big fellow oh
see here's why i should have brought
don't forget there's a i see it
oh god oh i had a plan
the plan was to hit him later hang on i
don't want to
play i was like i want to empty my clip
i want to reload
i want to like just take an arrow to the
face
there you go this is mine would you
shoot please how do i
still not have the reload there you go
are you happy kurt no okay
no because that was a dreadful display
it was absolutely it was
but this is the there it is
[Laughter]
i never see them in this way either that
or like you're invincible to them
where is the guy shooting them they came
from behind you okay
you see but now i've turned so much
behind what is behind me
where is oh oh oh there he is there he
is
come here you beauty you have one more
enemy
so you can make a choice to either try
and find that dude
sometimes they're just like moseying
around oh man i
i wonder if he's even trying to find me
is there any if there's any moment
what am i doing of course
i'm gonna take the thick skinned fickle
shooter attack no
yeah see sometimes you just don't get
he's got to make a choice
yeah please there you go there you go oh
get on that chest
that was easy dang easy peasy i
i'm feeling there's an exploited barrel
out there too
if there's any moment where you're like
i know you're like curt
help me out tell me what to do and now
you're like you need to shut up
you need to stop being in the back seat
uh you're beautiful this is this is not
normally you know what i what i do you
know um
i don't i don't have like eight hours to
you know slowly grow and
realize like oh the barrels you can you
can shoot them but i i knew about the
barrels
okay you had a plan i did the man
with the plan versus the game
i can yeah 409 definitely
definitely a bit better b for buckaroo
man uh all i know is uh
i gotta give me one of these tvs it's uh
so if so if you're streaming
probably i mean oh yeah my first setup
was
so many years ago still like my favorite
setup was a couch
tv setup i was determined to not like
sacrifice my experience
in doing it yeah so uh yeah i had my big
74 inch tv
it was only a seven four inches are
still ridiculous oh yeah and like and
that's why it's like one of those things
like walking into this room and seeing
this thing i was like
holy shnikeys like the bezels don't even
exist on it
um the difference between like yeah uh
like my old 74-inch it was like a dsp
and so it was just
it was uh so big
and so wide and heavy i did not even
want to bother with
like selling it or having anybody come
in to like carry it out
or you know it was weird i ended up just
dismantling that tv
and taking it apart and then throwing it
into like trash like dumpsters around
the neighborhood
like piece by piece it just sounds like
you're mysteriously getting rid of
something i know
it's kind of like i'm going to put in
all these trash bags i'm going to spread
it out throughout the city and no one
will ever find
any pieces to this tv i'm trying to say
it was just too much tv yes um
it was just too heavy and uh
couldn't could barely like fit it
through the door um
i don't know well and the thing is like
with cue luds specifically
um because they have a backlit thing
uh panel on them um to to push the
brightness through it
um they do tend to be not like
thick but like they're not as like you
know like maybe as like
thin uh as like people like like ideally
want
right with certain tvs but like just
looking at this dude and of course it's
like it's
it's it's already a massive view
um it's not thick and i'm like very
astounded by how they were able to like
do it right um how to cram all that tech
into
such a narrow space yes and that's
really what i was trying to get at with
my story my old you know i had to go for
dismembering
dismembering your tv and uh placing its
parts around the city so no one can
trace it back to you
right exactly you won't have to do it
with this because
you know you won't have to get rid of it
right oh yeah
and even if i do you know just two guys
could very easily
you know carry it upstairs whatever
but yeah now the picture quality of this
tv is
incredible and nothing shows it off
better
than the duke himself and me just
scrolling he's scrolling through a menu
screen like not knowing what to do yet
again
i'm going to stick with this plan i like
i like the handgun plan
um yeah so i love the lenny yeah lemmy's
good and then the uh
i love that guy the duke
i don't have a weapon to customize that
makes a lot of sense
there it is no that's the uh no no no no
no that one oh god you're right
you're right i'm sorry this one boom
yeah the non uh
normal pistol looking pistol this is the
one that i i did not
go for because i just thought oh i i was
hesitant at first two but i was like i
was like i should probably like they
presented it to me i should get this gun
i should see what it's about
um i don't think i really got the best
use out of it in like in the campaign
for that reason but once i started using
it in mercenaries i was like oh
like i get this thing like it's not like
um
it's not a machine gun right it's an
automatic pistol
it's like i'd say like semi-automatic
yes okay we're good here
here we go so the next the next area
we're about to go into is the castle
which probably my favorite stretch of
the game
and it's beautiful
like it is like every like every
corner like centimeter of that thing
like feels like so
well realized and trans like even like i
mean even just like looking at the wood
in this room which is this room is in
the castle
so it makes sense um the wear and tear
but i'm very very excited to see what
the castle looks like on the screen
because the village is like you know
it's like it's beautiful and it's
grimness and it's dark snowiness but
like the castle of course we start down
here but
we do get into the castle area i promise
in that basement oh here we go it's time
to get the gun
up oh this one throws a curveball at you
i forgot
oh that drum and bass oh boy wow
wow okay feeling like i should have
taken something else uh
the bonus time great
this guy i mean don't worry about him
yeah yeah it's because
i don't know that i have yeah i was like
oh yeah but
i forgot about the curveball they throw
at you in the opening last one oh yeah
there you go there you go
this guy is just like don't bother me
yeah don't it's poor dude you just shot
him while he's taking a nap can you
please
oh oh yeah yeah okay that works that
works
okay where's the chest chest
just tall i love how they cover it
back okay i was gonna say it's fine i've
got my thick skin but no we
started over okay there you go
okay this is very high tension
closing you in okay
whoa okay did you know that those
explode
here's a little protein for you man the
goal has spawned
so quickly like i find it amazing you
just like storm through this if you want
it without killing anybody
um beautiful they what now
i find it so like interesting that they
like make the spawn point like almost
instantaneous yeah that you can just go
for it if you want
there we go i need more
blood this poor guy he's just looking
for the bathroom is over here
i'm gonna mow you down he's like i'm
actually not with them
i mean i'm not here i was taking a nap
in a cell i find them just as annoying
as you do
i'm a civilized zombie
there you go buddy
now one thing that i am so terrible with
in games is getting turned around
it is the like turning around
uh no like getting turned around like
getting lost oh yes i had to consult the
map in this game like like every
sometimes it felt like every you know
five seconds
yeah but it's also i mean like for in
your defense it is a beautiful game to
explore
and like the map is like is something i
was constantly going through to make
sure like i collected everything and was
like obsessed about it is there like a
party going on
apparently uh well if i can you know
just lay this down through the bar it's
beautiful i love the way
the lichens like come around corners how
they like almost like
are on all fours like the enemies around
it yes oh yeah
everything well get them
come on okay
saliva is flying now oh boy
surprisingly still in the green though
getting a little a little sweaty
the ties might have to loosen the tie is
still
intact like you must be doing okay here
we go
man the game absolutely like tenses me
up because of the
the finesse on that aim and for me like
with their heads
you can move and like just like so are
so unpredictable like erratic in their
movements
that's a big part for me is like like
you have the knee strap yeah
for me it's just learning when like they
kind of slow down
it's like they'll have like a quick
swoop and then that right when they're
done that's right that's what i try and
that was really uh in the resident evil
2 remake
uh the zombies in that like moved
like so erratically they didn't move
fast but like the way they like moseyed
and swayed was like
so unpredictable to me that like i
actually even my knee strategy didn't
work
you have to go the other way thank you
um don't get lost this is what i'm
talking about
i'm your map getting turned around here
we go turn around
straight thank you thank you uh but my
knee strategy doesn't work
i still use in resident evil 2 but it
takes it still uses a ton of resources
to get through it
um here we go
but hey his face looks great not that
close
that blood has never looked juicy yeah
that blood is going to look more crisp
and gooey and there's another one of
those glorious arrows for you
straight to the face okay and we are
good yeah you're good nice
i'm getting out bam boom go go go go go
go go go
oh congratulations thank you we're
vaccinated by the way we can high five
yes and be this close which it feels
great by the way
it's there we go
oh i got to calm down is the tie too
tight
no the tie is fine the tie's fine i just
uh
i want to do well you're doing great
okay
i think you're doing fantastic in life i
always want
to impress people you look almost as
good as this image does
it's almost as if i saw you on the
screen and be like damn
that's a good one he looks great even as
with all that stress
stress sweat it does help yeah
earlier when i was talking like saliva
just kept flying out of my mouth i was
like
that's what i mean when i said i gotta
calm down exactly
okay the duke is always calm so
i mean i have to imagine that uh how
many areas were there in this
i think this one's four four okay
those enemies are going to get so so
this is this is the
uh the area of mercenaries where i there
is
i think it's like at the end of the
third area i
do buy a shotgun right that's when i do
like get to the point where like
i need to have a different means of like
if i run out of ammo with my pistol i
need to switch to something else
before i can like go back to the reload
system the og
yeah when when those uh the big armored
license started showing up i was like oh
yes they're gonna start throwing bigger
things at me it's
definitely more than i think a handgun
but i still do go i still like i still
am invested
in my cowboy pistol um
methods but i might i mean if i can
i'd like to get uh
decisions i know like do i buy it now or
after this area
i think i'm going to be glad that i did
and i'm gonna go for that bigger shotgun
now do you ever go with the with this
one that's usually the one i do go with
oh
but you're this is this is this is my
thing
it's funny what a creature of habit i am
because this is
again in in the play through i didn't
even really look at the uh the biggest
you know more powerful weapons because
at that point i had
invested so much in my older game that's
fine i think once you like it gets to a
point where it's like you like learn a
playstyle and even though like the
numbers and stats may be better on like
guns down the line like you still have
invested into like learning a style with
a specific weapon that you have
um i only go so like the only reason why
i go for
the one with the clip um is because it's
uh it's less of a spread it's more of
like a one-to-one shot
oh okay um and it's just like in certain
circumstances like this
i my crowd controls like one at a time
uh so i'm always like going for one
get one down go for the next one same
same um
but the shotgun you purchased is more of
a spread
but it might be good to get you out of
those hairy situations
i think uh i got two minds though i do
have two minds that'll be good
see now i'm considering selling them um
they'll be handy as well i think that i
still
decided i'll be glad once since the big
baddies start coming in
so this is the level i've been really
wanting to see like this is like this is
the environment that like
i was most anxious to look at
uh in this like this is like the
the like oh it looks so good i know like
you haven't you've only like come around
the corner but like
seeing just a glimpse of the chandelier
and like the wood trim um
it's funny trying to like uh because
this is such a fast-paced
kind of uh mode but i do i just want to
like
stop and just admire you know all of the
the artistry
yeah i mean for what it's worth like
this is this is the mode to show the tv
off with like this is the mode to like
show the variable refresh rate
um the low latency in the game mode so
like
it is the best way for us to see it in
this
circuit circumstance but like i would
love to like
take my time uh in this area and like
look at that
oh yeah oh yeah so this is where they
change things yeah
there we go can't have the the entire
castle available
come on there we go so i think there's a
time more oh there's a powerpoint there
we go yeah i
don't know why your brain is like i
don't want these it is exactly it's like
i'm not going for them
what am i doing there's some good
options here slow motion healthy
or you can move fast agile i think would
be great
especially because ethan winter's feet
are made of stone yes
and it again reminds me of that that
online uh
multiplayer yes that they're talking
about which how do you turn that into uh
yeah i'm interested uh i mean wait
wait there you go
the exploding uh ability of it
man i'm loving uh the lights here we go
smooth okay i see the door
oh oh the knee i did i did the knee
that's a good one it's a great setup
for the the head shots to come no
yeah so thankfully in mercenaries like
if the doors are closed like they don't
open
right um which is like again one of
those weird things i have to like
de-learn from uh
the actual playthrough of the game
they're all fake
why do i keep doing this because i just
want to see how beautiful it looks i
know the balcony is gorgeous it's
probably because i ran up that staircase
so many times
in the game thankfully
the next round you do get to go up there
i know that beautiful
because yeah that's where like the
really gorgeous stuff is uh
in like uh lady d's quarters
what am i caught on okay here we go hey
got your buddy there you go okay
beautiful just as i planned it
wow a lot of you coming out of that
hallway
there you go look at it just shrug off
those shoulder shots right now
animation's gorgeous i especially love
like how silly it is like some of the
killer animations is their whole body it
just
flies backwards just like it does a
backflip yes
all right so uh that door is closed stop
talking about closed doors
oh man after this one
this is actually horrific but it looks
great there we go
it's yeah but it looks beautiful it is
it just looks too real
too good all right
is there such a
yes thing just run you got you got the
quick boots on
i got you got to upgrade that clip i
think i do
that 12 is not enough yeah
here we go so many lichens in this one
which i got to say i love you know the
kind of fantasy
elements of this resident evil
i uh like i was it's
like resident evil has such a way of
like throwing all of his ideas out the
window
uh and trying something else and like
redefining itself and like of course
like people
you know some audience uh some players
may not be thrilled to go from third
person to first person
or even the fact that like bring back
zombies but i find that like that whole
thing kind of amazing because like
zombies haven't existed in the franchise
i mean they keep they were in
uh resident six but they had lo pretty
much left
like they're technically not in resident
before we haven't seen zombies in a
while we've seen parasite kind of
controlled things
um and it's really refreshing to see
capcom be like you know what we're gonna
do werewolves
we're gonna do uh we're gonna do these
like whole different
type of creatures and ghouls and things
that are zombie-esque but not
exactly um a bit more classic uh
you know kind of yes exactly i love it
uh because they do um
usually known so long because they bring
in a bit of like even
like sci-fi yes to it um oh yeah i mean
like especially like
like their ideas of cloning and viruses
and all this right
right everything they introduced early
in the franchise it's always like
a serum that yes characters have to take
uh unless they become
one of the monsters all right
now there you go
on this one it's like i just have to
start somewhere like i just want to
end the oh my god is that those yeah
yeah that's terrible here we go
i i could have gone better oh no no no
there you go nice
there you go right in the heart
beautiful now i love that i bought
this shotgun and i'm not even using it
oh yeah honestly i even forgot
i mean wait can it only hold two rounds
apparently oh what was that
it's reload wow that's horrendous that's
bad that is very
bad that's bad uh okay you should help
it up this is fine
this is fine you think my health is low
i think so
it's glowing right on the on the outside
and it's making me nervous
i'm sweating for you okay cause usually
uh in in the game the main game i'm just
gonna keep talking about the main game
um because it's great look at that
beautiful um
they they will they'll give you that
last warning they'll be like
use the help yes so i learned
uh you know to just kind of power up on
your lap for you
before you go on that would have been
handy so why are you telling me now
like i just i was sweating over the the
lat i was the seeing the the red on the
on the on the brims maybe because the tv
is so big you can exactly see
you couldn't see i'm having the glowing
red on the on the
uh on the edges of it i was just nervous
i just wanted to make sure we made it
through
you make a good point it's it's not
about whether or not i succeed it's just
how good the visual is
you know yes you are so immersed you're
so dead center
in everything that you were like i
this is one of those games where i feel
like i miss the forest for the trees
kind of thing because i get so barreled
down
like you know scavenging like even that
example like i'll be so caught up in
like
the details of a shelf it's like that's
when i'll take a hit you know from the
side
uh headshots do more damage yes i didn't
even look at the other
options it's okay you went with your gut
headshots
instinct it's i'm all about the head
shots 40 out of 40 beautiful
boom okay okay
we're doing a bit better
we're making it like compared to the
first attempt
oh yeah aimlessly wandering around
i think you ran out of time you didn't
even have the the glory of being killed
exactly um i i've always been slow on
the uptake
um for now i'm i'm getting that it's
much more like the the time rush
uh you know you just gotta get through
these
yeah asap uh
here we go so you kind of just use those
like when they give it to me i'm just
like this is just something i sell off
yeah
uh see now i'm thinking oh man how much
does that uh
because that's terrible right shotgun
could sell it
and buy the new gun i think i'm going to
try that
a bit of a misstep but
we'll try to recover but this is the
story
of the man that's right overcoming his
journey
overcoming his mistakes the struggle
struggle
to become the point yeah nathan winters
even no matter how good you shoot how
good the tv is you still move
like you can't tell if she listens
properly i don't know if i yeah
i don't want to be ethan i want to be
chris i want to be
smoking cigarettes oh yeah and uh it's
just
punching rocks alpha like to the extreme
punching those boulders kidnapping kids
the way this game kicks off you're like
whoa okay that's
uh that's interesting you want to be
that guy you're right
it's one of those things it's like you
you're like yeah it's just there's
something going on here
i don't know what i know chris can't be
a
murderer okay i'm uh let's get that gun
no you didn't actually sell your stuff i
don't think you did oh god
i'm getting i'm getting i'm getting
distracted oh my god here we go i saw
that chris redfield talk
the mind yes got me off yeah if you saw
that hot into the yeah that's the moment
you undo the tie
exactly um
custom goods sniper rifle don't need it
yeah these the layouts i guess for these
like stretches
i don't know i don't know if i'll go all
in on a sniper rifle
just because the movement i think is key
right you know you're just getting up
and close
right is enough so
let's actually sell the things so
there's some um
there's some there's some enemies coming
up in this next segment i'm not spoiling
anything for you
i feel free to spoil away by the way i
mean there's some there's some enemies
that you see
at certain parts of the games that come
into this next part
um that i'm excited to see you take on
oh man um then this tie is going to get
loose
and then the tie is going to get loose
but not too loose
now this is i mean you have a little
money to create the shotgun you just
bought
yeah which i am definitely gonna do uh
those pipe bombs though were looking
tasty i
did enjoy the pipe bombs
i'm a mine guy really yeah
at least like i can lure that like i
know where it's going you know like when
i set a mine down
like i can lure it right into it but
sometimes with those pipe bombs i'm
afraid that like
my throw might not be the best it can be
the accuracy may not be the best to be
and they're also more expensive
you make a very good point actually um
because yeah it was
i don't know i i liked being able to
throw something into like a cluster
yes um yes that is fun that is great
the tight corridor kind of situations
i'm just like and there's since you
don't get area damage
you'll get splash damage from it just
kind of let it set it down be like come
to me
see i didn't even know that yeah it's
very funny i find it like i feel like i
always get like a good chuckle whatever
happens
all right this is uh this is it
look how wet ethan's hands are and like
look how
and it's like uh that's how it's kind of
how i'm feeling right
right now like the sweat is starting to
pour out yeah but like it's able to read
how sweaty and stressed out you are yeah
exactly through the that's the next uh
tech upgrade for controllers
uh love the dual sense by the way the
adaptive triggers
uh with this game it's great adaptive
triggers the company with this thing
this this this theater size television
dude games are getting so immersive i
know
and this and like it's one of those
things like the ps5 that we're playing
on
um i mean also like you know 3d audio
like residual village was like one of
the big games that they were pushing
like
it was built in mind with 3d audio um
and playing this with headphones um and
like here
like uh hearing where things are coming
from uh
and i know i've been obsessing i have a
weird obsession with these arrows that
are attacking you but like you can hear
him zip by it's fantastic oh yeah
um i need to get uh i have like
you know a 5.1 surround sound set up in
my
living room right but i don't have the
you know
the rear speakers hooked up still i have
to do that
i have a real incentive to do that here
we go
shotgun oh boy it all looks so
smooth the crispness
and like how does it feel like i mean
like you have the dual sense and you
also have
like this refra the variable refresh
rate
um low input lag oh like it feels
fantastic
um because i have felt that before um on
uh
my old tv where like if i forgot to
switch into like the game mode on it
uh like it is a very noticeable uh yeah
it's kind of amazing
like uh setting up hdr and then like
like the game mode and like the low
latency like it's kind of like um
uh astonishing like like how much of a
difference there is
like you don't really notice it until
you feel it and see it like this
um yeah i it like it's
it's kind of a game changer
oh boy i'll see myself this is
boy what is he doing oh he's dead i'm
sorry
for a second i thought he was still
alive
and i am confused like what is she even
doing out here
yeah so that's the funny thing so uh
for those of you who've played village
who played this game um these are lady
d's daughters
that are now uh stalking the man
um but in this in this case you know
they're not supposed to be outside
that's actually what uh
makes them crumble apart in this game in
mercenaries mode they're like
all bets are off oh i've never seen that
mercenaries
usually they don't disappear like that
huh it's probably because they're
like backing up like so far okay there
you go there you go
so yeah okay i was wondering if there
was a
trick to them as well oh gosh
is he down there you go
i really have to just like stop i can't
like flow too well in this game
like uh just one to the next i have to
like stop
get your bearings like you know aim then
fire
i mean that is uh i mean i think that's
due in part to eat in winter
is having his boots filled with cement
yeah right
oh my god whoa okay okay these guys
is he what what
here we go this is a little confusing
there you go
looks like what is happening uh are you
please be dead okay sweet
moving on uh let's see 15-48 man i've
got a ways to go that is not a door
so i think the way out you were just
there so
uh yeah straight ahead in that doorway
gotcha
i'll hit this direction uh uh
yeah i don't know what it like uh does
the windows just look a little different
to me in a good way
um they looked a lot smoother like the
pieces falling out yes
for me yes oh yeah
it's glorious brilliant man there was so
much glass that i missed
in the cabinet there's so much glass i
miss breaking just taking all my time to
shoot all the windows out
it was usually like uh the little
cabinets i don't get those but like
oh yes yes i didn't even think i thought
you were just reminiscing about shooting
windows
he's like man there's so many great
windows to shoot out dude i love
destructible environments
like they again you just keep going back
to like the immersive nature of games
but
man it does a lot uh to have a world
that you can
interact with oh oh oh nice shotgun
might have been a good idea
getting hit by her sucks yeah oh god
please get back
get back that was good lady there you go
skadoosh
well maybe you shouldn't have yeah maybe
you should have like
chilled out yeah we could have parlayed
and stuff
i'm a reasonable man here we go
so many zombies coming out of that
ground
i like how they're coming up through the
floor like the floorboards yeah
um this is fantasy all right
so straight ahead that way there we go
more handgun blamo and
here we are yeah but you guys see like
how wonderful his teeth look right
you're gonna see the detail in these
arrows again
i'm glad you realize why i'm taking
these hits yes i want people to get the
full
you know experience wait let's see
the extreme close-ups oh gosh these guys
have got to go
go
[Laughter]
no time for puzzles only time for
scattering yes
give me the bob's shoe up now
let's uh see if we can head on so go
downstairs
the opera or the uh oh boy
come here i see you i see you
the squatting is me just squeezing no
that's you that is you
uh like strategically dodging moves
going for the knees
lord all right uh definitely oh this
feels so weird
the shotgun i usually have on the right
on the d-pad
not a good one all right uh where are
you at where are you at
i want you nice that was a perfect shot
the big man come here you oh
watch out he's out uh i don't need this
too much gun for these weenies
so would you suggest watching titanic on
a tv like this absolutely okay
dude i'm curious for uh what this tv is
going for because it is this has got to
be
uh possibly the most gorgeous tv i've
ever gained
i it's i think this is about the size of
my wall in my apartment currently and
that's not exaggeration
i think i think um i might just have
enough space
for where my current tv is which is
about half the size of this there we go
um 10 enemies left my goodness this is a
this is where yeah this is like i kind
of was referring to this where it's like
they start to like scatter themselves
out and you kind of have to like
run around to get them so it's not the
most
natural flowing thing healthy max hp
increases i think the middle one you get
hp for killing them which is nice yes uh
initial attack has more damage when the
enemies hp's full
i want to go with this uh
even though it might be kind of close i
mean i think that's okay you haven't
been taking
you took a bit of damage last time i
don't think i think even alright this
time
i really tend to like glass cannon
you know full offense kind of
builds in games a bit more risk
reward on it uh i feel i'm going
backwards no i think you're
no you're right this is good okay um
because i think the
i think the goal is outside again oh
okay um
so right and then left
i think maybe i'm lying to you don't
listen to me look around
what about oh wait it's right here
usually it's here it hasn't spawned yet
i think you need to keep the exit oh
okay all right they're probably somebody
downstairs i know
you have 30 i see that i've seen it oh
no
i fought so hard oh god nothing
um great
grand oh man
wait this is a big one okay
man i believe in you even if this
doesn't go well
this is butt this is like where where
are the dudes at oh we can
write
this is fine you know what we're we're
gonna i can give it another shot
it's okay it's not your fault man it's
it's not your fault i kind of feel like
it is my fault
no it's not your fault it's me
sweating just distracted by the beauty
but all that's that's the thing is
like i want to slow down and stop and
like admire look at it yes
see it it's never looked better but i
can't
i gotta move on i gotta shoot and and
just
keep shooting okay okay
so area three
that's uh it's a c i'm so sorry it's
fine
uh i love the castle area i'm ready to
go
just more of an excuse to look at it
right and uh
that last one i had a big blunder you
know i bought the wrong shotgun
this is true didn't even really use it
so
we're gonna come back even harder
better faster stronger
so the one thing that um going back like
i was kind of mentioned this earlier
uh in terms of like is it was kind of
tricky
with the new generation of consoles um
because of certain like specs and things
that you like had to be considered and
like of course like you know a ps5 would
work on any tv
any any tv in hdmi um
but it is relieving to know that like
this specific series like the xl
collection that tcl has is basement
and boogie woogie um made for people
like me
yes i really appreciate anything that
has that plug and play
uh you know aspect to it yes and
eventually i mean it's like it's gonna
get to the point where it's like
no matter uh like
we are we will have to upgrade our tvs
to be able to get like
that full force uh pinpoint immersion
um that is intended by the developers
that is intended by the consoles and i
think that's like the important thing to
remember too is like this is how these
should these things should be seen and
experienced
for sure until i plug in a commodore 64.
and use and use its aipq
upscaling technology uh to make
that blue uh starting screen look as
best as it can syntax error never looked
crisp
insert tape to the best point
like a good percentage of the audience
watching this are just like
what are they talking about go search it
yeah
yeah or don't uh but just know that this
tv
with the right if you personally have
the right cables and
components to uh get a commodore 64
running on one of these dudes with
probably through audiovisual maybe even
hdmi there's some wizards out there
yeah just know you can make it happen
or maybe watching speed on vhs uh
um it'd be interesting to watch yeah
like
films yeah like specifically on vhs um
i have got to get this gun and get on
with it look here we go
uh yeah don't let me distract you i've
got so far to go yet
so far to go uh
but okay and i'm
you know i kind of get like dragged into
you know like the next
phase like the next level of of uh you
know
uh fidelity and all that because my
standards tend to be
rather low right coming from the atari
commodore 64 background right
it's all mind-blowingly gorgeous to me
um
but uh yeah then i sit down for things
like today
and take a look at this tv and it's like
ooh maybe well i think like
i think you said like plug and play
earlier uh like the ability to do that
like
that's usually like while i
i have an appreciation for certain
fidelities uh
in certain places um i think i'm a
little like you or i'm just like i just
want to be able to enjoy it and play it
and get it going
um and you don't really understand how
good it is until like you see it in a
certain way
um and i think just for me personally
it's like i do have a modern consoles
um and knowing that it's like
if i can get a specific if i can just be
like oh i know dcl
the qled and these xl collections
they're good like you're good to go like
i can just plug in and skip
bam boom
um here we go so and now i have to worry
about like you know like i
could know that the gamer mode is you
know ready to go and
i can switch back to speed on vhs and
we're good um
yeah anything because i am so forgetful
as well like uh anything that will
automatically flip back into a mode that
is best suited for
you know what i'm playing or watching uh
that is very good for me
did you see the jukes you can
eat in there oh so see that was good
that's fine
that was a good example though of that
pipe bomb uh you know
causing trouble yeah hey get i love that
there you go get that chest shot in
there no no no no no
oh boy oh boy this is fine this is fine
there you go get him down come here
chest shot chest i love being able to
see like the clarity that his like lips
are missing
yeah oh man
see that's the thing where like again
like all i can really focus on is
like that heart i'm just staring at like
the heart i'm looking at his teeth
all i care about is look at this this
tube missing his lips
those details i feel like we're talking
we're getting at like uh part of what's
you know what can be enjoyable about
watching a stream
generally speaking where the audience
people watching the the game play yes
like you can focus on
anything on that screen like how good
the windows look
right right exactly and so like or that
guy's lips
i haven't had and like i haven't been a
uh you've allowed me the great pleasure
of being a backseat
watcher for this game because i've i've
only played this game alone i haven't
had a chance to like
watch someone play it yet my girlfriend
watched me play
we had a wonderful time but it's it's
fun to just sit back
now i get to be in that position yeah
watch over the shoulder
look at the lips the judgment yes oh
golly
hey um
i know see what it does it it compels me
to
to play better you know i don't want to
be an embarrassment
in front of uh you've been great my
girlfriend or you or our audience
that was i'm sorry what were you saying
kurt oh
man that's uh that's that's humbling
i don't want to be an embarrassment to
myself i know the timing i don't know
the universe hasn't been
when i told you earlier those explode
like there was like a point in which
just like shoot that and you're like no
i have a plan
[ __ ] it's like those blow up those will
help you
this is uh i is that
can i get in there at all on mercenary
mode no i don't think okay i mean maybe
uh i mean
maybe there's secrets the world uh knows
that i don't
yeah um in which i applaud you there you
go if if there is
just email us follow you
yeah you can get me at mad at man tv yes
you can in fact get inside that secret
area or you could just
tweet a game spot or someone anyone
there you go beautiful
oh no no no no no okay
139. uh see this is the flower
the flower i i tend to for some reason
look overlook the flower
i i used it in hardcore difficulty but
um
and i have no idea what it's used for
you shoot it and it like kind of like
trips them up a bit they're like oh i
can't see through okay the flower
i get it yeah yeah puff of smoke okay
a little distilled disguise i was always
just you know
slicing it with a knife and and
expecting there to be an item in it
i did that the first time i saw it i
felt really stupid i was just like
hitting i was like what am i doing
that's exactly what i did like the whole
way
yeah uh knives do more damage no out of
reach
see this is where it's it's yeah i guess
i'll go out of reach
you know and hope i could well
i'll maybe go for the uh that rifle this
time around
see you in your element i do
uh the rifle i'm not gonna say my bacon
yeah a number of times
in the the main i did not use that gun
there's some there is something
satisfying about it like it has like
that same kind of like resident evil 4
quality of like
popping a dude and then hearing like the
click of it all but i
i just found myself moving away from
that gun this entire game i think i kept
it for my playthrough
still just as a backup um i tell you
okay the uh
the adaptive triggers with that gun felt
fantastic
like the the tension of like zooming in
yes yes and when you squeeze that
trigger
it's uh much more tension on the trigger
if i recall
okay so we're good oh arrow none of that
come here come here there you go
slim bam strawberry rhubarb pie
uh is that we're good
uh we're kinda good
i just need a moment ty the tie is still
tight i know
i'm not even ready to go well because
i'm just i'm just thinking about the you
know the mic
i can't can't get it too low okay can't
like you know toss it off
put it around my fort my head like rambo
style
all right that's when you know i'm
really struggling
when the ties are on the head yes and
you go into ptsd
john rambo
oh man um what was that look at the
dude's feet
i want him to have a heart attack
make that noise i heard it yeah
couldn't tell what the hell was going on
uh and actually today was the first day
that i saw the animation that went along
with it yes
the cigar ash falling on him oh is that
what it is yeah yeah yeah it's like it's
him uh like in his and all of his
voluptuous glory until the cigar ash
falls on
just a little sizzle uh
so what are you gonna be doing this time
oh man um
i think i i'm just gonna go with the
shotgun i don't know if i can do the the
sniper rifle
for these these areas it just doesn't
feel right
because once they get too close then
it's yes that scope is very close
quarters uh the mines
i want to hold on to those mines this is
good
i like this this is fine this is good
this feels right it does
just feels good i'm feeling solid i'm
feeling confident
that's a that's it what else can you
sell with mines i guess
you could what would you do
what would kurt do let me see well i
don't know if i'd buy the shotgun yet
um yeah the mines would be enough
uh i think
i usually probably wouldn't buy
i mean you could just sell the shotgun
ammo
and you'd have enough for it and then
you could just
yeah do that that's a little sad i don't
know but you would have enough for it
and like you know you could pick up ammo
along the way
sure sure i like
where your head's at yeah but not there
let's go
i gotta speed up these these segments
just prepare and get back into the
action
all right menus don't really you know
show off the
oh i can't afford anything else can be
crisp and clear
oh man in all of its 85-inch 4k
qled this is going to be glory yeah
this is going to be rough though just go
for it i should have powered up that gun
more
slam bam oh well it's that's the way to
go you also have 375 bullets
right hand gun bullets i've got to be a
bit more free with my
ammo it's the resident evil brain
just i can't let go of it
to me that's just what survival horror
is it's like ammo
yes is just making making every every
choice
uh matters every life or death choice is
uh
cause whether or not you can get through
it yeah so back
in lady d's castle okay this time you
got to be
serious i see the power up and i'm going
to go for it
because i'm learning what would be the
first movie you would watch on this
switching from uh game mode to um
i was thinking of like two thousand
words oh you said you did say fear and
loathing
i did yeah fair loading so we did kind
of go over there a little bit uh just
the garish colors uh terry gilliam i
just love his his visual
flair but you could at least upskill
some monty python
oh yeah aipq
i don't know it's one of those things
where like anything you put on this tv
yeah it looks fantastic
uh brake shot gruesome gourmet
slow motion yeah seems nice
uh see but then i'm leaning towards the
brake shot
just for like that slight instinct uh
maybe slow motion let's try slow motion
okay slow motion
going full instinctual mode here oh
there you go all right pick up all that
blammo and let's go
here we are wait don't worry about that
they're certainly moving slow
i also find it like i always like forget
that uh russian four's
a current or like previous gen console
game two
um so it always kind of astounds me
because i think it's like one of the
best looking games
uh so far in general like just its
ability to like capture
like these details and uh it's ray
tracing and just like it all just feels
um so well realized
uh that i often forget i was like oh my
god this is on a ps4 like you can play
this on an xbox one
that was uh yeah like actually the first
game that my girlfriend bought on my ps5
yeah this is so funny
um and
just like it's you know it feels
next jenny while also being current gen
it's kind of astounding
but accompanying that with tv like this
uh something that is like able to like
truly like
bring those qualities full force uh and
your reaction times and all of that
just like i like this game a lot i like
what it looks like
same uh it's really got me like fired up
about resident evil again yeah
um you know i've always enjoyed the
series but you know as like we were
talking about
drama and tangled uh
lore oh man it's so uh it does remind me
in a way of like anime yeah kind of it's
it's really more of like a japanese
uh approach to storytelling that maybe
doesn't necessarily go for you know full
realism
right it's you know everything is
elevated yeah you know
it feels a bit more dare i say epic yes
no absolutely you used it correctly
there we go yeah i try not to
because that's another word that's just
been kind of overdone faster eyes
yeah i love that those dudes explode
nobody else explodes with those things
like explode into like a yellow goo
exactly uh is it going backwards again
no so this is you go uh that way
yeah straight ahead to your left yep and
here we go
and that's i don't know where that
occurs slowly move it's glorious
just empty the clip look i got 400. i
was about to say i was like you were
loaded uh when will i stop playing this
like the main mode here we go like in
now i only i i'm going to share this
it's a bit embarrassing but
i played through the game on standard
difficulty that's fine
good for you and people hold on before
we
before you continue people need there's
no shame in how you
what difficulty you want to play a game
in all right
whether you want to start on hardcore
standard or casual
you do you right it's all about enjoying
how you want to enjoy it so yeah
don't don't don't don't pre-face the
shame oh yeah well
for me because you know the stream and
the whole concept of being the struggle
uh still you're still the man versus the
game
sure now i because i didn't stream this
though i i just played it privately so
i didn't have anybody to impress except
my girlfriend right
so i just are you asking if i'm being
impressed
uh i know you're not impressed but
that's
what i want to get around to asking is
how was this game on the harder
difficulties
oh it's uh uh hard so
i have a shameful story being the expert
that you are yeah i have a shameful so
like i did
uh play this my first time around on
standard and i regret
it almost felt regrettable to me i
wanted to play on hardcore
uh it felt like it should have been
played on hardcore um
i went through this game without a
problem um i'm also like
a residual veteran and i like knew all
the corks and all the things that to do
and like i had my own survival tactics
like already in place
and i kind of wish i had started out
hardcore for to begin with and i'm now
playing it again on hardcore and it's
like it feels like that's the way i
should have always played it it feels
like
the perfect balance of like true
survival
horror and a little bit of action like
sprinkled together right however
i suggested somebody i told someone i
was like do yourself a favor
start on hardcore that's the way to play
it thank me later that was the thing i
said oh thank me later
thank you later uh the whole rest of the
day either texting me like i don't think
i could do it
i don't think i could do this like this
is way too hard i can't get past the
opening segment
yeah um and i feel like i've ruined that
friendship
i feel like i've like like did it on
purpose i was
like that was good it's like eat this
mine i know what am i doing
this is the guy that i want to hit with
the mine would you come on come on come
on
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go
go go
go go
go go
go go
go go go go go go go put it down i did not
put it down yet
and uh it feels so weird knowing that
it's not really gonna
oh there we go oh you get them good good
chest chest chest there you go oh
beautiful
now one more somewhere uh
i'm probably going to say did you make
no no there's nothing
yeah don't listen to me i think i'm
going to have to i have to let him go
unfortunately
oh power up did i just hear someone
oh don't go for thick skinned you've
been going through
i know they'd go i love immediately like
not the thick skin
not the thick skin you don't need it
we've been there done that hp recovers
slightly that could be nice
uh speed increases that's that's the one
i want
that to me is meant for this mode so you
got one more
or you just i got time
hey hey there it is that come here you
hey
sad guy just looking for the party and
here that's it you got all
40. no there's money there's money i'm
not gonna run back too
too far but definitely want to grab that
money
beautiful
and here we are so we didn't get to see
you
get all the way through this one but
we saw you endure die a journey of
survival
persevered truly living up
to man versus fame
i like to say you know what i lack in
talent
i make up for in tenacity and this
concludes
our fantastic playthrough of resident
evil village
mercenaries mode but none other the
great
the man the man versus the game we saw
him
come into this and become a legend did
we though
you what you went from a c rank to a b
ring you know it got better you found
your
you found your footing you found your
way and of course
i mean so much of it uh is due in part
to the ability to be
fully immersed in this tcl 85-inch
q-led xl collection tv absolutely uh
it's glorious and i feel yes as long as
i'm making progress
in the game in life as long as you keep
putting one foot in from the other
one that's what it's all about one ethan
concrete
slow foot in front of the other but man
versus game
where can where can people find you
where can people continue to watch
uh your struggle to become um
a gamer i mean you're already the gamer
the struggle to become the man versus
the game where can people find you uh
i'm so glad you asked me kurt uh you can
find me over there on twitch.tv slash
man versus game
uh and then that has all the other info
that you'll need uh for the social media
stuff
so won't waste time talking about it in
the meantime
i want to thank tcl one more time for
being a part of this for sponsoring this
video
and for providing us this amazing
television to watch anything from
terminator 2 to titanic switch right
into game
mode have that perfect fidelity
variable refresh rate low latency gaming
it's brilliant absolutely brilliant once
again i'm kurt davina
thank you so much for man joining us
today to play resident evil village on
the playstation 5.
till next time keep playing games play
them however your heart desires
but make sure you're playing them on the
right tv okay see you later
you